احدث الخلافات وليس اخرها في علاقه لا
طلاق فيها لكن قد ياتي الخلاف الاخير على
هذه الشراكه قائد مجموعه فاجنر بروجين
يرفض اوامر وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو
شايجو امر الجميع وحدات المتطوعين بتوقيع
عقود مع وزارته بحلول نهايه الشهر في خطوه
لزياده فعاليه الجيش الروسي بيان وزاره
الدفاع وان لم ياتي على ذكر فاجنر الا ان
وسائل اعلام روسيه اعتبرت تلك الخطوه
محاوله من شايغو لاخضاع مقاتل فاجنر
لسيطرته بريجوجين رفض توقيع اي عقود مع
الشايغو واعتبر ان القرار لا ينطبق على
شركته
خلاف يعكس عمق الازمه بين الرجلين فبلغت
مبلغ كسر العظم على ما يبدو تلك ازمه في
سلسله متلاحقه من الاتهامات والشتائم
اطلقها الاشهر الماضيه ضد المؤسسه
العسكريه وصلت حده تخوين كل طرف للاخر
ازمه العقود تزامنت مع اخرى بريكوجين يريد
ايضا فسخ عقد تموين مع وزاره الدفاع بصفته
مالك شركه كونكورد المورده للجيش الروسي
وجبات الطعام منذ عام 2006
وفي رساله
لجا الى هذا الخيار بسبب مطالبه مسؤولين
بوزاره الدفاع لشركته بالتعاقد مع موردين
جدد معتبرا تلك الخطوه انفاقا غير خاضع
للرقابه كما ان بعضهم بحسب بروجين من دول
غير صديقه روسيا
خروج الطباخ الرئيس الى العلن بعد سنوات
من العمل في الظل اصطدم بعدوات يقال انها
تزايدت بسبب طموحات قد تجعل مصيره خارج
مطبخ الكرملين
لمتابعه المزيد البار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات